welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther we're gonna
forever removed a romantic subplot
between Neymar and shuri which is really
insult to injury after they use VFX to
rub out that
yes I look and sound a little bit
different because I'm shooting this
video in a new Rockstar's HQ but really
it's the same blue dungeon it's just all
one big room that's fans continents and
dimensions I mean let's face it shuri
and Namor went from watching on
underwater Sunrise to the next thing we
see them in immediately in a different
location wearing different clothes
exchanging jewelry and in my experience
what happens in between those two things
is uh well a few weeks of being in the
friend zone until she moves on to a
taller guy but if I look like to
nochuerta I mean this movie's editor
revealed to Newsweek that there were
takes of no more scenes with shuri with
a romantic subtext coming from the
actors he went as far to say that there
was a whole other version of the movie
in which shuri reacts to Neymar giving
her that bracelet by asking am I queen
of talocon now while how scripted this
romantic moment actually was is debated
there legitimately was a deleted shuri
Namor subplot in this film a huge
section of the script that had to be
reworked and let's be real you can't
leave these two alone for too long
before someone sticks their spear in the
other I'm talking about the fight come
on get your mind out of the gutter
that's where I live let's dive in okay
the editor of black panther we're kind
of forever my Michael P shaver told
Newsweek that he and director Ryan
coogler removed tanks in which Leticia
Wright and tanochuerta seem to have some
romantic chemistry more than the
Diplomatic relationship between a
princess and a rival King editor said I
think what's really interesting is there
were takes where there was some
connection there and at one point in an
early cut we discussed like hey do we
leave it there do we just put it out
there let's just add some complexity to
the relationship but then you've got to
watch out for portraying for example
shuri flirting to get what she wants as
opposed to being a diplomatic leader and
becoming the leader that she needs to be
that she'll get to at the end and shiver
continued they relate and I think that
anytime we can relate to somebody there
can be undertones of that kind of thing
you know what I mean honestly we've got
to keep ourselves sane and laugh a lot
especially with the tougher moments or
the serious moments so we would always
joke that when he gave her that bracelet
they were married now and she didn't
know it there's a whole other different
movie where Sherry's like wait well Adam
the queen of talocon now so you can kind
of see this is more of a joke that he
and Ryan coogler had in the editing Bay
based off of how Latisha Wright was
playing it in that particular take and
after this went around last big
production designer Hannah beechler
stepped in to clarify quote while there
was a curiosity and seemingly a mutual
experience of loss never any scenes that
would be considered typical romance or
physical intimacy were filmed so what we
ultimately focused on was Neymar's line
where he says only the most damaged
people can be truly great leaders and
that's planting the seed of the shared
trauma that she realizes at the end but
still even Hannah Beasley says there was
a curiosity there and one wonders if the
relationship was scripted to be one of
rival leaders sharing loss why did some
takes contain enough throbbing curiosity
that the movie's editor unprompted
brought it up in interviews like this
well the answer is the fact that this
movie's second act was reportedly
completely reworked even more than just
some removed flirty eyes according to
shaver himself in other parts of the
interview that really fewer people are
talking about he revealed quote there
was a subplot in it where shuri and Riri
work together to help Namor do something
in talocon and it was a vessel for sure
and reread a bond and to feel their
smart scientist connection that they
have which we were able to implement
later in the movie with reshoots when we
took that section out that solved one
problem but then came several other
issues because then we felt like Riri
wasn't as involved in the story in the
movie Riri basically became a MacGuffin
as opposed to a real character which we
don't like people should be fleshed out
real people so we had to find ways to
have them connect for example he added
later shuri and Riri together coming up
with the solution to defeat anymore by
stopping him from being able to absorb
oxygen through his skin but the editor
continued once that gets taken out then
there was less of a relationship but
there was also less plot stuff that was
keeping us informed so then we realized
okay while shuri's down there in telecon
we need to have Ramona be more active to
get her daughter back and we need to get
to Lupita a little quicker we need to
get her involved now when you watch this
movie you can pinpoint the moment where
this reconfiguration took place now we
are always hungry right like yes hungry
for the latest Easter eggs hungry for
the newest trailers hungry for more
movies and shows featuring our favorite
Heroes and stars but also just literally
hungry the amount of time I've had to
think about food vastly outpaces the
amount of time I've had to get and
prepare tasty meals which is why I love
to use factor and yeah I know I've said
the same thing about hellofresh but
that's because both are true factor is
now owned by hellofresh which means that
there's a wider array of meal plans to
choose from I switch between both Brands
and now new Rockstar's viewers can do
the same thing while getting a
discounted deal on food you know the
thing I'm still thinking about Factor
cuts out the stressful meal planning and
extensive prepping so meals come
together in minutes taking all the
guesswork out of what to make for
breakfast lunch or dinner Factor meals
arrive pre-prepared and ready to eat in
two minutes even faster than ordering in
takeout
I'm the egg man
all right feel it oh I love shrimp
um it's so good I'm a happy shirt yeah
see how easy that was you
easy one of the things I like about
factor is how it makes possible to
achieve your daily fitness goals through
nutritious purposeful eating Factor
offers keto calorie smart Chef's Choice
and vegan plus veggie options which
includes Seafood meat and plant-based
meals meal plans offer variety with a
rotating weekly menu of 25 and more meal
options and Factor plus add-ons choose
your favorite meals or let Factor craft
your order based on your taste
preferences and meal history to get
started with Factor today head to
go.factor75.com
rockstars60 and use the code rockstar60
to get 60 off your first Factor box
again that site is
go.factor75.com
rockstars60 and use the code rockstars
60 to get 60 off your first Factor box
there's a scene where Neymar takes shuri
on a tour of talocon and he shows her
this underwater pyramid structure that
we never get too much information about
shuri says it's beautiful it's made of
vibranium and Neymar's like yes in the
depths of the ocean I brought the sun to
my people and no one knows what the [ __ ]
you meant by that but hey it looks cool
but before we get any information on
what this is exactly we get to shuri as
Neymar continues off screen saying I
know you want to spare the life of the
scientist but and then back to Namor on
screen as he says now you see what I
have to protect but from this we cut to
the scene where Nakia finds the water
hole in the jungle and Ramona directs
her to go rescue shuri and then we cut
somewhat awkwardly to Sharia Namor back
in Neymar's man cave where he gives her
the bracelet and says you are the first
person from the surface world to visit
telecon please take this as a symbol of
our gratitude what why isn't a more
thanking shuri here what did she do to
earn this like hey here's my mother's
bracelet made of a sacred hemp you get
to have it now for visiting I mean I
guess it's an incentive to get her to
join his side but when she ends this
scene not joining him why would he let
her keep his mother's bracelet I mean no
wonder Leticia write it a few takes to
the scene with some romantic subtext but
this scene serves several functions to
the movie Namor giving shuri the
bracelet that she'll use to
re-synthesize the heart-shaped herb name
or inspiring shuri with the line of only
the most damage broken people can become
great leaders but overall it's a bit
tonally clunky like ideally every movie
scene is its own well-crafted story arc
of Shifting character outlooks and
values that Express the movie's theme in
a clever way not every scene in every
movie is going to be a winner but this
scene is just clearly meant to be some
more connective tissue to get the movie
from A to B and to set some stuff up for
the Final Act and in that regard it does
a good job but now it's clear why this
scene feels so totally strained the
movie's editor is confirming that there
was a major second act subplot where
shuri and Riri use their scientific
knowledge and Engineering skills to help
Namor somehow in talocon and I think it
had to do with this mysterious
underwater solar device that rises from
a vibranium pyramid perhaps these two
women fixed it so the people of telecon
would have some more efficient
infrastructure so that they would
desperately need and something Sherry
and Riri would have unique insights on
how to do that would explain why we
never really got an answer of what this
thing really was why the editing around
this part of the movie was so choppy why
that scene in the cave seems so
overburdened and yeah white Leticia
Wright might have played these scenes
with a bit of subtext that could just be
read the wrong way in certain takes
there's just so much there for any actor
to have to communicate emotionally and
find don't go to the film she does a
perfect job and yeah overall this film
does not at all get derailed or anything
as a result of this part we mostly just
come out of talocon a little confused
why we didn't see more of it and the
film moves on to more important matters
that said if you want to come out of
this movie with the head Cannon
assumption that before Neymar killed
ramonda and debrief period when he and
shuri were alone unaccounted for in a
version of this movie where shuri helped
Namor fix his pool light to earn that
bling that helped her roid up and regrow
her garden yeah I think shuri and Neymar
and the bfx artists erase the evidence
let me know your thoughts on this you
can follow me on Tick Tock Hive
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow the
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you